welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host rachel cruz ramsey
personality and
best-selling author is my co-host today
we'll be answering
your questions open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five chris is in baltimore
hey chris welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave um this is amazing for me i
actually grew up listening to your show
my parents
turned their life around with your
advice so i'm really appreciative well
i'm honored how can we help today sir
um so i'm 22 i graduate college
on sunday yay what's your degree in
that's in economics congratulations
thank you um i am lucky enough to have
no debt from school and i have a job
locked down i also have three months
expenses saved
um and my fiance is in school to be a
physician's assistant currently
and because of her program she'll incur
some significant debt
so i'm trying to weigh um saving for
retirement while i start my job versus
saving to be ready to hit that debt hard
once we get married
chris when do you guys get married um
it's not going to be until she graduates
so it's over a year away
okay well for you i mean i would i would
definitely be focusing on your
retirement right now
because praying everything i'm sure you
sound
very responsible very in love so i'm
sure this wedding is going to happen
but what i would do is still um take
advantage
of the 401k at the company if you have
that or a roth ira
and then on the side if you want to save
some money
just in general and what you can earmark
that for for a year from now when you
guys get married that you can throw at
her debt
for sure because it'll be your debt
together at that point or you could even
use it as a down payment on a home
um later in life too whatever you want
to do but just earmarking it
on the side but not
i would still fund retirement how much
student loan does she have
that is she going to have um it's
likely going to be at or around 100
000 ooh that might change the answer
okay and you you make what
i'll be making 65 000 a year okay and
then she'll be making probably about
that when she comes out roughly two so
you have 130 000
income with 100 000 in student loan debt
yeah
with it being that much i might uh delay
retirement for one year
you would pause it really yeah and just
let's pile up cash and get ready for the
marriage
because as soon as you walk down the
aisle you're a hundred thousand dollars
in debt
and you got to get that cleaned up then
before you start retirement and you're
22 you've got plenty of time to get to
retirement
either answer is going to be okay
there's not
neither one of us are you know neither
one of our answers are wrong
it's just a matter of i i think you're
it sure
it sure would be cool if uh out of 65
000
in 18 months you had put aside 60 and
you only had to knock out 40 when you
got married
well you'd write a check after you
walked down the aisle for 60 because you
had a pile of money laying there
and and then you'd have to knock out 40
when you got married and she passes her
her uh her bars and uh you know her her
licensing and all that and is able to go
forward but yeah i
i because you're going to have to stop
retirement after
if you're only going to do it you're
only going to do it for one year that's
fair
and then you're going to stop it and get
because you're going to be back in debt
but either ways okay i mean you could do
your roth ira for one year like rachel's
saying
it's not a not not a wrong answer here
uh
the fact that you're 22 you're
graduating in economics she's graduating
as a pa
and you're even asking these questions
makes you a genius
i mean you're just so far ahead of the
rest of your classmates
because they're going to wander around
some of them for a decade before they
can find a checkbook
and so you're just way ahead dude you
know so
neither one of these things is going to
mess you up good good call thank you man
and congratulations
rondell is in new york city hi rondell
how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call i'm
well how are you better than i deserve
how can we help
um so i am looking to so i just sold my
house
and i'm looking to purchase a new home
so i'm wondering if i should get
a two-family home that's going to be a
bit more expensive obviously real estate
in new york is
super expensive but i plan on renting
out half of it
and that income that i project should
bring me down to that
25 uh debt income ratio
so i was wondering uh what are your
thoughts on that or should i just go for
like a regular house
uh i probably would go for a regular
house and the reason
i would do that personally is a
two-family home
the good news is your renter is next
door and you can watch out for what's
going on the bad news is your renter is
next door
and if they want something just gonna be
knocking on your door i mean it's um
so it's a it's a little bit awkward at
times to be in the same property
the other thing is a two-family home
ninety percent of the time
that is sold is not owner occupied
meaning it's going to be an investor
buying a duplex buying a two
two unit product and uh so your
buyer on that kind of a thing is always
an investor most always and it's
therefore they're looking for a deal
your buyer on a single family when you
get ready to resell
is retail it's joe and susie just got
married once that house or whatever
and so and they pay retail so single
families
of the exact same price will typically
appreciate
better than a duplex will just because
of who the end user is when you get
ready to flip out of it
but uh it's it's not a bad idea it's not
the end of the world but
you know sometimes all we look at is the
math and we're going oh the renter's
going to help me pay and that's going to
just be grand and it's like
no yeah it's so there's a lot of crap
involved in all that that's not gonna
necessarily be fun
so um you know i
i probably wouldn't i wouldn't
personally
because of quality of life i just
wouldn't want to live right next door to
my renter
it's just i just personally wouldn't
want to do that and that's just and i've
got a bunch of rental property and i'm
not a snob i've been a renter that's not
the point
but i just that's an awkward
relationship well it's the convenience
of what they have
towards you yeah i mean you're pulling
in the driveway and they're both falling
in the right way and it's like
you know it's just weird next-door
neighbor weird relationship
so but you can do whatever i mean it's
not a bad thing
but it's certainly not a slam dunk oh
yes definitely take the income because
there's more to it than
than just that when you're when you're
renting property
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five and by the way there are
once you learn
how to work with people in the real
estate business
and you learn how to interview
a potential renter for one of your
properties like you were interviewing a
team member to come on board with your
company uh
it's not dissimilar you you you can
learn to weed out
people they're going to be a problem and
you can learn to put in really high
quality folks
a lot of the rental property that we
have rachel's husband winston runs our
rentals
runs all of our real estate and he does
a great job screening the tenants in
and it's not unusual for one of our
tenants to have been on a property five
years
and our friends they become friends
because they're good people
you know and so you know you can get
you know you never hear me say we're
putting down renters we're not
because i've been one and we work with a
lot of really high quality people
that for whatever situation whatever
reason at this point in our life they're
renting
so you can you can get if you do the
proper screening you can get a good
situation
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality two-time
best-selling author
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today we're answering your
questions about your life and your money
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two
five her new book rachel cruises
know yourself know your money will come
out in just a couple of weeks
january the fifth we will be shipping it
it is on pre-sale right
now and a whole bunch of you have bought
it ahead of time thank you tens of
thousands of you
and we appreciate it uh if you
pre-purchase it
before january the 5th i highly
recommend that by the way
not only does it help us it helps you
that's the important thing
you are going to get a call with a
ramsey preferred
financial coach this is for a limited
time
you're going to get the know yourself
know your money audiobook
the know yourself know your money ebook
and
an exclusive video lesson from rachel
cruz as well
a hundred and fifty dollars in bonus
items when you buy a 20
book uh so why do we go to all that
trouble why do we bribe you like that to
get you to buy a book ahead of time
because it's a great book number one
you're going to get it anyway
you might as well get all the free stuff
up front because it helps us with the
best seller list
to get them get a bunch of them pre-sold
and so it really does and and so that's
why we push it
like this and that's why we give you so
much free stuff okay can i can i
interject
sure you're allowed to it's your book
okay and the reason
for the bestsellers is not just for the
title of it it's because
if a book it's on a bestseller list
other outlets pick it up they see it
they read it
so then other people hear about the book
to help them yeah it makes it i
i don't want people to think oh i just i
want to be the best i don't know i
i just already been number one twice you
don't need another one but to do it yeah
so that the book it is it causes the
book to be able to help them
go more that's right that's right yeah
yeah so that it's out in the world more
because again when people can understand
why they handle money the way they do
everything from how they grew up to
their tendencies their dreams their
fears all of it
it gives really this validity of what
we've been talking about that personal
finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge but
knowing why you have the behaviors your
ha
you have help you change those behaviors
that are unhealthy and win with money
faster so it's a it's a fun new deep
dive
into how to look at money and yeah when
you pre-order you get 150
50 worth of free stuff so check it out
know yourself know your money at
daveramsey.com
washington dc todd is on the line hey
todd welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you doing great man how can
we help
all right well we actually live in
alexandria virginia um
thinking about refinancing our house i'm
trying to
really try to decide if it's worth it um
i wanted to give you some current
scenarios to see what you think what's
your current interest rate
uh current interest rate i financed last
year at the end of 2019 i got 3.25 on a
15
15 arm okay i've been paying extra
because me and my wife are in our late
50s and we want to get this damn thing
paid off as quick as we can and i like
that
okay so it's a 32 a 325 arm
yes 15 15 through my credit union yeah
and what's the offer on the refinance
so the credit union is offering 2.5 i
was going to switch to a 15-year fix
no points that they're telling me
approximate closing costs because they
currently hold my escrow and all that
would probably be
6500 to 8000 that's the ballpark what's
your balance
closing costs uh we owe 384.
we only oh the 6500 included
escrow setup but you get your other
escrow account back what's your closing
cost not the 6 500.
be about 3 200. i'd say yeah about that
right
yeah 35 i think okay so yes you're going
to do this
here's why here's why let's walk through
the math all right rough and dirty
you're saying you're saving three
quarters of a point
so i'm gonna just say one percent of 385
is 3800 bucks
you're gonna save 3800 bucks the first
year
got you you broke even after year one
everything after year one's gravy on the
biscuit
you're gonna save 3 800 bucks or so
every year
until you get the stinking thing paid
off not quite because your balance is
going to go down but
overall i mean you're going to save tens
of thousands of dollars over a 10-year
period of time
by doing this refi absolutely i would do
that
and right now i've been paying 1100
extra every month and
right now that's just just paying that
extra saving me about
almost 119 000 in interest and if i
switch to 15
and pay just another about 300 extra a
month to keep
the same payment i'm doing right now
exactly i'm i'm
i'm shaving off another 40 000 in
interest
that's the shortening of the mortgage
which is one analysis
but the way you analyze whether to
refinance is simply
your interest saved the difference in
the two rates times your balance
versus your closing costs gotcha
and that tells you whether to do it or
not and you have a one-year break-even
point
on a break-even analysis on that and if
you're going to stay in this house
that's a no-brainer
you do that and considering it's an arm
versus getting rid of that arm is a
benefit too yeah
yeah that's um never do an arm folks uh
especially in the lowest interest rates
in 50 years where do you think it's
going to adjust from here
up we just don't do arms no no no no no
no
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ryan is in
roanoke hi ryan welcome to the show
hi dave how are you now better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i graduated this spring uh from
virginia tech
and i'm starting to take a look at
paying off my student loans and
i was introduced to some of your videos
through youtube and i'm trying to figure
out the best way to go about that
cool how much student loan debt do you
have ryan
uh just over 50 000 i think like 51.
okay so do you have any other debt
besides that
um a car loan or
um a couple thousand let's go left okay
but it's
paying off quickly yeah yeah and is the
50 000 student loans is it broken up
into multiple loans or is it one large
student loan um it's multiple loans and
i guess that's kind of where the main
question lies
i've been saving up to try to take care
of the highest interest rate
uh one of those loans to save myself
some money
and after watching your videos about the
debt snowball i'm not sure if i should
do that
or take care of a couple of the smaller
ones with lower interest rates first
yeah sorry one last question how much do
you have saved you said you've been
saving to
throw at the at the highest interest
rate or you're just saying as you're
getting money that's what you're paying
off first
um saving to do that i
i still have a couple months or i guess
now only about a month until they
actually turn on
six months after oh yeah that's fair i
think my payments start
in uh in january much do you have in
your savings account
um right now 11 000 after an end of year
bonus i think probably more like 13.
okay and what is your smallest student
loan
uh 6700 i think
perfect okay so you probably heard this
on youtube we're going to list your
debts
smallest to largest right
so today i would pay off your car
and your smallest student loan
and you think that that would be the
best you know the best way i mean
i'm i'm definitely a saver i know rachel
talks about are you a saver or a spender
um i'm definitely a saver so i don't
think there's a problem to keep going
with it that you think that i should
take care of the smallest loan and the
car
first yeah because when you look at the
debt snowball versus the debt
avalanche is another way of looking at
the highest interest rate uh what you're
doing
with the debt snowball not only have
studies come out to show that it is the
fastest way to get out of debt
but what ends up happening is as you
start knocking out those smallest debts
and you eliminate it completely and what
you're not factoring in
is just the emotional toll and what
happens
to human behavior when you start to get
quick wins
and so by knocking off the small step
first you're actually
doing so much to keep you motivated and
ryan as a saver
you know putting we're going to tell you
if you have 13 000 saved off your bonus
putting it all towards debt except for a
thousand dollars is going to make you
feel very uncomfortable
so just heads up on that too but that
gives you an urgency as well
so by paying off smallest to largest i'm
telling you the behavior change that
occurs in you
the motivation continues to get those
quick wins
absolutely now let's do a little math
okay fifty
two thousand fifty three thousand
dollars minus
thirteen is forty and you make
what do you say if it made fifty can't
remember i don't know if he could told
us what his income was he
uh but so how quick you're gonna play
off 40 uh
maximum of 18 months you're gonna do it
real fast now dude
get after it get it this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help
trim those expenses and make sure your
family is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something at a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180
000 worth of bills and got close to 75
discounts chm shared the rest of the
expenses
to see if chm is right for you and your
budget
check out chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code the magic word
ramsey and you'll get a better deal
today's question comes from monica in
nebraska
we are on baby step two and we are in a
large amount of debt because of various
stupid
decisions my husband is really not
interested in working this program
i am the one that does all the financial
stuff and i am the main br
breadwinner he has basically said tell
him
what can be spent on various categories
and he will make it happen
so i've decided to work the debt
snowball is it wrong to move forward
when he
isn't really supportive well
so monica the deal is the when you're
married when you both can work
together and be on the same team and go
towards the same goals you have the same
vision
you're gonna get there faster because
you're both gonna be willing to
sacrifice you're both thinking about it
day in and day out
like that is what you're working towards
as a team so you're going to get
progress a lot faster
it doesn't sound like he's not
necessarily not supportive
he's kind of like just tell me where i
can spend it and i'll spend it and
that's kind of it he's kind of checked
out i wish he was more
emotionally not interested in working
this program
but he said just tell him what he can
what can be spent in certain in various
categories and he can
i would i would tell him i'm not your
mother
be a man go down to walmart on aisle
three and pick you up a backbone
okay no really monica you're a little
wuss
i think seriously you need to step up
you need to man
up and walk with your wife beside her
yes he does but
he's not asking the question it's monica
so what does monica do i know
monica needs to call him out
can you imagine if i walked in and told
your mother
that i didn't really care and you just
do whatever you want and you take care
of everything and i'm just going to sit
over here in the corner and wish can you
imagine what your mother would do
she would un-joint my butt that wouldn't
even come close
no really i mean call him i know but
welcome to this is
this is this is a lot of this is a lot
of people situations though in america
it really is
and it's so the woman is has become the
one
she is the cfo of the household i mean
she really is the one doing the money
doing everything uh in regards to money
and so
you have to realize women out there
number one that when your husband is on
board you win faster so what do you do
about it number two
go and i would say sit down and have a
frank conversation
as respectful as you would like or as
davism as you would like to take it
that's up to you but to say hey
here here's what i'm feeling here's what
i'm thinking here are my fears here are
my whys why do i want to win why do i
want to get out of debt
and talk to him have a relationship have
communication so you guys can get on the
same team
and so when that doesn't happen i'd also
say bring in a third party
i mean at that point at that point you
have more marriage issues than money
issues
because you're not willing to work
together and in marriage that's what
marriage is you are living life together
and you're unified in every subject
including money
um so monica rachel's right about one
thing you are you are
100 more capable than he is
you have the natural gifting you're the
cfo of the household
i am not discounting that at all and so
you're the one that's probably going to
implement the plan you're probably even
going to design the plan
but this idea that he gets to sit over
in the corner and be spoon-fed
whatever he why just tell me when i can
spend
oh brother that's just ridiculous
that's absolutely absurd and so you're
going you're probably the one that has
the
the
greater talent in this area and
obviously the greater concern for
that's not going to change but he does
need to step up and say all right i'll
walk with you in this dream
i'm going to come with you let's look
together at the budget you do the budget
i'll look at it with you
you're probably going to be the one that
produces it because she's the cfo of the
household i don't care if it's a man of
the woman that's a cfo
that's not my point but i got to tell
you she's going to end up really
frustrated with him being a wuss like
this and it's going to damage their
relationship
because i have coached people in these
situations after
oh ladies try to do this for 10 years
and she finally is tired of being
married to a little boy
yeah no that's what i was saying earlier
though is a lot of women possibly
listening right the second
are is exactly in her situation yeah
they are finding themselves that their
husbands do not want to participate
don't want to go along with it not that
there was not that they're saying oh i
want to know he's just
passive it's the pat yes it's just
passion yeah
and that's just that's just gross
seriously and this is yes and the
wussification of america
and the the deal too is that we say
life problems usually masquerade
themselves as money problems so there's
probably other areas in her marriage i'm
assuming that
she's frustrated that he's not whether
it's kids or whatever
the situation is there's a that's the
person that's what's that's the roles
that have been
in place not just with money and so
being able to help him get on board
is going to help also the marriage
exactly because we it's a prerequisite
to you winning here
yeah yeah absolutely you are not going
to be able to pull this off
with this with the formula that you were
using it's not going to work
i mean it may work for a little while
but eventually it's going to blow up for
relational reasons and financial reasons
um he may get tired of being dictated to
at some point um you know being told and
well my wife don't let me do this i mean
what kind of
hook gross and so um you know
that that so that it's going to blow up
it's not going to work
we've done it too long i mean 30 years
of doing this i've watched this
situation unfold over and over again
so what he has to do and you have to
call him out on this or go see a third
party a marriage counselor together what
rachel's saying is exactly right on that
um the you have got to go
and get not he doesn't need to become a
nerd and he doesn't need to become the
one that drives the budget
but he's got to be in agreement and he
has to actively
emotionally vote and say all right i
i look at that i agree that that taking
those steps is going to take us to a
dream
i agree on that's a lot different than
sid and then
you go and do the stuff that's fine no
problem with that but when he's just
sitting back and you're trying to drag
him along and he just gets his little
allowance
oh my gosh it's true
it's true i agree with that joe is with
us in rochester new york hey joe how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm on baby baby step two i've been
watching you on youtube for a few months
and i noticed you had a consistent
message of saying be a contributing
adult
so i recently accepted a promotion at my
job and i believe i can afford to move
out
my family thinks this is silly and they
say i should live at home until i pay
off all my debt i wanted to know if you
agree
how old are you joe 25 25 how much debt
do you have
45 000 000. what do you make
about 55. what do you do
i provide solutions for my company
well i guess we all do okay um
are you married married kids single okay
no
okay yep i mean
so go ahead you go ahead you go ahead
we've been arguing through this whole
hour go ahead okay
so so mathematically could you save
money on rent for a year or two
live with your parents use what you'd
pay for rent to throw out the debt
get out of debt faster yes absolutely uh
but there is something to be
said about being a self-sustaining adult
and saying hey out of my budget i have
rents and i have things i have to pay
that i'm taking care of myself and
there's a level of dignity there joe
uh that i think is really important so i
don't know i
i'm kind of one way or the other i mean
i probably would be for you to go
and just pay rent and start living on
your own
but if you're like really aggressive
with this debt and you want to get paid
off you're making sacrifices you're
doing whatever you have to do
and there's that intensity because
you're working towards a goal
i wouldn't be mad about that all three
of my kids joe
are uh did extremely well i'm very proud
of all three of them including rachel
winston
um but in and they were all hard workers
and they were all responsible with money
when they were under my care in college
when they came out of college and they
went on their own with their own
income and they were continued to be
responsible with money
and and they took on some extra expenses
to not live under our roof to do that
in all three of these responsible young
adults cases
i saw them grow up two more notches when
they were on their own
happens okay and you got to pay your own
life bill and you got to wash your own
clothes
and you got to pay the rent and deal
with the landlord
and something else happens and so i
would do it i'd move out within the next
few months i'm not mad at anybody
i'm not being mean to anybody but it's
not just a math thing it's a
developmental adult thing
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two 225 aaron
is in tacoma washington hey aaron how
are you
hi i'm doing well how about you better
than i deserve what's up
um yeah i just found you on black friday
and i have dove into yours and rachel's
books
and been listening like crazy wow thank
you but
i'm yeah i'm still finishing baby step
one on my four walls
um we're required to re-roof however
as i'm approaching baby step two um i
have a possible funeral
and burial in the near future my
estranged
father has placed me as executor
i don't know how much these things cost
and i know there won't be any cash
in his estate until life insurance is
paid out
so how much does that cost and
i would assume that i need to start
saving for that before i jump into baby
step two
where is he um
he actually was in hospice in california
but one of my brothers picked him up and
brought him back to washington
okay to call the funeral home in the
town that he's in
okay and just um and uh
tell them you have two problems uh
number one you have an estate that is
gonna be formed soon he's in hospice
and um there's not much money in the
estate so
um this sounds awful but i'm gonna say
it out loud okay
uh it's what i would do if i were in
your shoes i'm gonna call the funeral
home and go i need the budget funeral
what's the what's the bottom line
and you're probably gonna find five to
seven thousand
okay okay uh as long as you're not in
some kind of major metro area and you
get a hold of some kind of
crazy funeral home but most of them have
a budget process
okay for families that don't have any
money
um okay that i mean
and i you know you can explore all kinds
of different options
cremation or whatever it's up to you and
look into
those things and just but you know
gather up
the dollars associated with the three
best options and then you can think
about the three best options okay
um and uh uh that that's your first
thing and then you know what your target
is
then the second thing is ask them if
they will accept
and a tell them there's a life insurance
policy involved but there's no
cash in the estate will they accept an
assignment
of the life insurance proceeds up to the
cost of the funeral
most funeral homes to do that
okay an assignment
okay look here i'm the who's the
beneficiary the estate or
you i am
okay so you can come take them policy
and show them
i am the beneficiary on this policy and
it pays x number of dollars
a lot more than you're gonna need for
the funeral right okay
yeah and um and you go i'm willing to
assign
let's just call it if the funeral was
sixty three hundred dollars okay i'm
just making this up
but if you know i'm willing to assign
the first sixty three hundred dollars
out of this
and have it paid directly from the
insurance company or
just give you a uh you know an agreement
a written agreement that the money as
soon as it comes to me will go to you
but
they will work with you because you can
usually collect that money with most
insurance companies within six weeks
okay and so they're used to having to do
that it's not that unusual at all
because a lot of families don't have the
cash
but but do have life insurance so two
things one is gather up the information
and then two but the problem is it's um
it's icky to talk about it's awkward
even just you and me talking about it's
awkward
sure yes yeah absolutely i mean it's
your dad he's estranged
that's icky uh you being having to fix
this and take care of all of it when
there's not much relationships
icky again and now we're talking about
the cost of
funerals you know but it's just life
it's just life i mean
right and so we're just going um
what's the least expensive way we can
take care of his
final remains in a in a way that you
20 years from now are proud you did it
that way you know
yeah i mean up until i found you i was
just gonna put on a credit card so
i definitely want to plan that i don't
do that because
well they may ask you to do that but i
would just say that's not an option push
back on them
okay again they're used to working with
families that have access to the cash
but they've got to get it out of the
estate somehow
that's not that's a fairly normal
transaction because most people
don't do good planning and most people
don't have any money
so when i would assume to that in that
part of business as well there's
different levels there's ways you can
probably spend a lot oh yeah um so
making those choices
i think what is is important to be smart
and to have the date in the dignity and
respect of course of your dad like you
said i like that advice though like from
20 years from now
you don't know regrets and you know a
lot of people have really strong
opinions about their uh final resting
place and so if you're
listening right now and you haven't
really planned that and you care a lot
um you can go to a funeral home and
pre-plan we do not suggest you pre-play
pre-pay don't pre-pay for your funeral
but you can sit down and go look
i don't want the freaking bentley i want
the chevrolet
where i want the bentley i'm not going
to care at this point whether what color
the thing is
it's not going to be that color for but
about six months anyway so it doesn't
matter you know
and so you know you may have different
you know we have wicked sense of humor
around the ramses but
um but the uh but yeah i mean you can
decide all that for yourself
and then your heirs don't have to
uh because you know you're uh you know
rachel probably would like spend a lot
of money to make sure her dad rested
beautifully and you know daniel would
put me like in a box no denise denise
one
so i probably ought to go plan this so
that i get what i want out of this
oh man no i'm going to be in heaven so
i'm not worried about what
what the box looks like so i'm not
sweating it but
it's a it's such a weird discussion and
and it's hard
and and i think too erin is she's smart
to be thinking all of this ahead of time
yes because when a passing does happen
estranged or not
the grief comes i mean they're right
there's just the human spirit and
emotion that goes
through when you lose someone and when
as many decisions can be
made ahead of time it's better that's
what we talk about
a will that's why we talk about having a
legacy drawer so everything's in there
like
to to limit as much as you can on the
tactical side for your family
is is a way to say i love you as well
yep yep
so we have always said don't pre-pay but
always pre-plan
and how much detail you want to go to
into on pre-planning
actually causes your wishes if you're if
you would be
aghast that your children spent twenty
thousand dollars on the casket and the
vault
then go over there and pick out the four
thousand dollar one and tell them that's
what you got
you know that's all i want or vice versa
yeah be a gas that they put you in the
4000 and
little cheap skates instead i wanted to
be in the 20. you know i mean okay so
so another way of looking at this too i
feel like we i've heard you say this
before
that in order to have for to have life
insurance the reason you need life
insurance is if someone is dependent
upon your
income but if you don't have money is
there a reason to have life insurance
a small amount just for burial or burial
costs
is that that would be a reason to get
life insurance as well if there's no one
if you can
but that's a ten thousand dollar policy
i mean it's not
you can get it with your checking
account you know it's not it's not a
it's not a big expensive item
but the idea of pre-planning through
anything that's highly emotional
uh certainly uh you know having a your
your
your will uh life insurance
funeral plans all those kinds of things
is just it's a gift
to your family folks for you to do that
at the end of the year go on
mamabearlegalforms.com and you can get
your will done in just a few minutes
it's very easy to do if you don't have a
will or you haven't updated it
you need a will
and you know if you go ahead and do it
like this week then when everybody's
around next week you can tell them if
they're in the will or not
sit down and have a discussion go ahead
and do a reading of the will while
you're alive
if you want to piss them off do it while
you're living yeah okay no but we say to
do that though right yeah i would do so
to do that conversation though don't
surprise you're joking about it but for
real
talk about the stuff we uh we have a
meeting once a
year yes with the ramses we call it the
win dave dies meeting
and it's like when something happens to
dad or mom or both
here's what it is but as a ch as a grown
adult child i'm so thankful
that you guys are talk about it and
communicate about it so it is a gift it
really is
it's my monty python move meeting i'm
feeling much better it's just a flesh
wound
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money rachel cruz is my co-host today
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and my daughter
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
jessica starts off this hour in tulsa
oklahoma
hi jessica welcome to the dave ramsey
show
thank you so much for taking my call
dave and rachel i'm excited to be here
on
sure how can we help oh yeah okay a
little background my husband and i are
in our early 30s
um we are just finding dave ramsey and
by we i mean
we have 30 000 in our savings we're
about 165 in retirement
and all of our debt is just in our
mortgage which is about 103 000.
so due to cobin i'm now a stay-at-home
mom of three young kids
um so down to one income and i'm just
trying to decide
um how do i get my husband get so
intense
um just because we're down to one income
and have never been here before
and because it's just our mortgage he
kind of
thinks it's well fine everything's good
there's no reason to just be crazy about
it but
and then hard in the family and things
you know we can knock this out in seven
years so
am i do i need to just break a little
bit or
do we just hammer it it's probably it's
probably in between
the two of you um gazelle intense
is no eating out no restaurants
no life because you're getting out of
debt in baby steps one through three
because you're broke and deeply in debt
and you have to sacrifice and work
like crazy to get out of debt once you
have your emergency fund in place and
you're debt free but your mortgage
you move on to baby steps four five six
so four is fifteen percent of your
income going into retirement five
kids college and sixes pay off the
mortgage early that is not gazelle
intense
that is intent that is intentional but
not intense
and so um you know i so i probably want
him paying more attention than he is and
i want you to lighten up a little bit
somewhere in between you see what i'm
saying what do you think rachel
yeah i mean that's a good analysis
because now that you're down one income
jessica
it's naturally going to slow back you
guys have less money coming in
and so in order to do retirement still
in order to save for kids college and
putting money towards that there may not
be a ton right at this moment to throw
extra at the house depending on what you
guys have
we'll see what you're making uh we bring
home
monthly around 4 okay all right yeah you
can put your 15
towards retirement start something for
the kids college and then any other
money you can find
in the budget um we're going to do some
living with it i mean you need to buy
that couch or upgrade that car or
whatever you pay cash for all that so no
more debt
and then we're going to go ahead and
start anything extra we get we're going
to throw out the house you get a bonus
you get a little inheritance whatever it
is we throw it at the house throw the
towers right at the house
and most families will pay off that
house in about seven or eight years
maybe nine
but we don't need to just say uh on his
side oh it doesn't matter
everybody has a mortgage no everybody's
broke you don't want to be everybody
exactly on the other hand you don't need
to live on beans and rice and have no
life at all
and everybody's miserable so you can put
five dollars more on the mortgage
sure okay we definitely have a little
room there i think it's just
getting him to the point of
understanding that we don't have to be
like everybody
else well you don't want to normal
almost broke
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck
and i would give you guys credit though
jessica because you guys aren't normal
right now i mean you have
you have 30 000 in savings no debt but a
mortgage i mean you
you guys are not normal right now in a
great way so you guys have
made great headway um but yeah it's just
that that little extra at the
at the mortgage so you're already weird
yeah you're just trying to him from just
trying to keep him from nodding off at
the wheel he needs to just keep driving
that's all
so you're you're in pretty good you're
in really good shape but
in terms of just the way you communicate
through this
really all you need to ask for and
expect is intentionality
and not accepting oh well everybody has
a mortgage
that's not okay uh on his side he needs
to be able to expect
well we're going to save up and buy this
item or do this thing
and we're going to do some of these
other goals and you know what i find too
jessica
for men specifically when they
see something visually it changes the
game
a lot of times so even just like taking
your mortgage putting it in an excel
sheet or do a mortgage calculator
but show him how much of the money is
going to interest show him exactly like
what is happening and if you paid off
your house in seven years versus 15
how much you're going to save an
interest how much extra you're gonna
have to go and invest
and just do a little mapping out since
you're the nerd and you probably like
this stuff just do okay
for 15 years from today if you're 30 at
45 years old
if we still have the mortgage here's
what we'd be financially
if we paid it off in seven years and we
invested for seven years a mortgage
payment
here's how much more we would have so
the visual standpoint for a lot of men
helps when they see the math agreed open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five lloyd
is in boise idaho
hey lloyd how are you i'm doing good how
about you dave and rachel
better than we deserve what's up i want
to
see what you think about i want to
upgrade my motor home
and i'm going to need probably around 50
000
to do that um i'm 58 my wife is 57
we're both retired um my net worth
is about 1.5 and
uh total in cash is about 1.2
um but i wanted to know what you thought
about where i should take that money
out of to fund that motorhome and i was
thinking
of i have 33 000 checking i was going to
take 10 000 out of there
i have 29 000 and savings i was going to
take 5 000 out of there
and my wife's roth ira she has 72 000
i can take 15 out of there and take 15
out of my
ira or roth which is 78 000. i'd leave
your iras alone
leave those alone let them grow tax-free
this other money's just sitting there
so where would you take that money from
then well you said that you said there's
a
i mean you pull 10 out of that first 33
and after that you said there was
another account that was sitting with
cash right
right savings account was 79 000 and
who's like you said that was
29. okay you can clean that one out
what's the
what was the one that was 79 oh that's
uh
the roth rra don't want to touch that
one
all right so you got uh uh 39 10 and 29
so where are we going to get the other
20 without tapping into retirement
well that's what i was trying to wonder
where we should how we should do that
you know
i thought you said you had a lot of cash
how much is it all tied up in retirement
the whole million seven no no
um about a million two is in retirement
tired of retirement
okay now we do have a joint account that
has 284 000
in it what's that um that is
just our regular uh account your
investment account just an investment
account
yeah just simply but it's not in a
retirement fund of any kind
no it's not we'll use some of that yeah
that's fine hey man you did great go buy
an rv
you did it touchdown you're a
millionaire seven
you did it you worked your whole
freaking life man live like no one else
and later buy an rv
there you go that's what i mean fifty
thousand out of a million seven for a
toy
you dadgum right that's a good ratio do
that
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show we're glad you're with us america
open phones at 825-5225
merry christmas to you deanna is with us
in denver colorado
hi deanna how are you hi dave hi rachel
nice to talk to you thanks for taking my
call
our pleasure how can we help well i have
about 300 000 in life insurance on
myself
i'm a recent cancer survivor this year
right now there's no sign of the cancer
so that's great news
yes i have thank you i have a cash or a
whole life policy for 61 000
that has a cash value of 6300 right now
i'm trying to decide whether to cash it
out and put it towards our debt snowball
it would move our debt free data for
about six months
but because of the cancer me getting
term life to replace it
is not super great and i'm just
wondering what's right not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen this year at any
reasonable rate anyway
um so you have how much life insurance
on you this 63
and you said 300 with the 63 there's 294
without it there's 233 okay
and what do you earn um i make about 53
000. okay so you're a little bit
underinsured
either way um
and you're married yes i am and what
does your husband make and how much
insurance does he have
he makes 50 000 and he has about 475
000 on him so he's in better shape on
his insurance
yeah um i wouldn't drop it right now
okay i hate whole life and i know
99 of the time i would tell you to cash
it out but um
you know we need to get you get cancer
further in the rear view mirror
so we can get you more insurable and get
you back up to about
half a million a total at some point and
when you can do that
reasonably within your budget part of
doing that will be to drop this
okay but it's out of an abundance of
safety because you're just not going to
get insurance for a little while i mean
right you're not in i mean you can get
it but it's the cost is going to be
astronomical indiana your husband is his
a whole life policy or is his term
no his his term okay okay i was going to
say for him to get out
if it was whole life that's a good point
yeah so you can call xander insurance
and uh even talk talk with one of the
reps and start to get a feel for
uh you can even run an application in if
you wanted to
uh just to get a feel for what because
they'll bounce back and go
well we can't cover you now but we'll be
able to cover you in 18 more months
or in 24 months the rate is going to
drop in half of what it would be today
or something like that so you can kind
of start planning
the further cancer gets in your review
mirror the you know the more likely
you're going to get insurance and the
less it's going to cost
okay well thanks for your advice we've
paid off a lot in the last two years
thanks to you guys and
i just love the program so thank you
thank you we're proud of you well done
congratulations we didn't pay it good
job can you beat cancer that's even
yeah there's that little assad yeah
bigger than the debts
much bigger much bigger teresa's in
tampa florida hi theresa how are you
hi i'm great thank you and rachel for
taking my call i appreciate it
sure how can we help um i have a
question
i work for a very small company there
are seven employees i'm a geriatric care
manager
and i make about 40 000 a year
and i had a client that passed away a
couple of months ago
and out of the blue her family sent me
a check written out to me as a gift
they said it was a small token of their
appreciation for
taking care of their loved ones and it's
for five thousand dollars
wonderful that's a lot that's a lot of
money for me but
um our company doesn't have a policy
against gifts or about monetary gifts so
my boss is trying to figure out
what she wants me to do i have sent an
email
to the person that gave it to me and
said thank you so very much i really
appreciate it but
you know i don't feel like i can accept
this money but they
are insisting that i keep it good they
should
and it's not in your boss's business if
he doesn't have a policy
well that's kind of my question i i have
um
in in my heart if if they insist that i
keep it if i can't get out of it
um i have definitely some charities that
i wanted to go to
and some things that i know were near
and dear to my client's heart
teresa no no
you're supposed to have this money you
served these people
and they were grateful you're supposed
to enjoy this money
you don't need to feel guilty you didn't
do anything wrong
have you ever gone to a restaurant and
left a tip that was a really nice tip
for somebody that gave you a great did a
great job waiting on the table
as much as i can do i know but if you
left have you left a nice tip where you
were kind of like that was a good tip
yeah did you want that person to feel
guilty and go give it to a charity
because they didn't deserve it no they
deserved it they waited on your table
and did a good job
and you were honoring them and it
honored you to be able to do that to
give them that tip
don't mess this up this was for you you
did
great this is an atta girl well
thank you for that i just i i not only
feel guilty i also my boss has been
kind of mentioning different ways she
thinks it ought to be spent
i don't care what he thinks it's not his
money it's not her money
it was made out to you right from this
family
yes okay now if i am your boss
if i am your boss i am going to be not
with you
but this raises a question in the
business that you all are in
if i'm leading this organization i think
he should or she should put a policy in
place
that limits gifts because we don't want
the caregivers that people are paying
for with our company
to get wrong motivations where they try
to snuggle up with the
person they're taking care of in order
to get money
and we don't want this to turns toxic
you didn't do that
but if i'm in your business i want to
make sure the caregivers are not
being toxic in order to uh you know try
to get some sugar daddy and that's
the boss's problem though yeah but that
and that's their problem and this just
makes them recognize that but they don't
get a vote this is your money
absolutely i mean and i want you to
enjoy it if you want to give a little
bit of it
mac i'll give you a maximum no more than
500 the other 4 500
has to be spent to further your life and
your income
this was for you teresa
part of part of the art of giving is
also learning to receive
and it's very hard for some folks to
receive but this is for you
please don't give it away it is
dishonoring to the people that sent it
to you
if they wanted it to go to the ministry
uh that would support a ministry that
the person that died
uh they would have given it to that
ministry they didn't give it to them
they gave it to you and considering they
wrote you
a check thanking you they probably have
been giving elsewhere they're probably a
family of givers and they probably said
wow you took care of my mom that
my mom loved teresa she probably you're
hurt that that that woman you took care
of probably talked about you teresa all
the time to her family
when she passed they said we want to
bless teresa cause she blessed us so
you're good
you're good you're good that's it and
and
we've had the pleasure as ramses to do
that kind of thing many times and we
fully expect it to go to you
and i you know if i if i were on this
family side
i would be telling you the exact same
thing and by the way they are telling
you
the exact same thing i'm telling you you
keep it
and no it's not your bosses and know
your boss doesn't get a vote if your
boss wants to put a policy in place for
future things
then that's okay they can do that and
that might not be
a bad idea and to kind of help ease the
the pain for you teresa of taking this
five thousand dollars
you know we will say like if someone
gets a big inheritance or a grandparent
leaves a chunk of money to a grand son
or granddaughter whatever the case says
we do say yeah there's a level of you
can honor their legacy really well
and use this money maybe to pay off debt
or to save or
or to do something great to further your
life you can just go spend it i don't
care
but for you to ease that a little bit
maybe you say you know what i'm going to
help
pay down my car and start working my way
to get out of debt whatever the case is
whatever you do with it think of the
lady that you cared for
is she smiling when you're doing that
with that money
and then you know you're honoring her
legacy she's in heaven watching you and
she's she's smiling
she probably is already smiling about
this conversation
you're awesome teresa you have a sweet
sweetheart oh
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money 2021 is right around the
corner thank god
uh this new year take time to understand
yourself and learn how to make healthy
money decisions
rachel cruz my co-host is going to help
you unlock the psychology the strengths
the challenges that come
with each and the brand new seven
money tendencies found in her new book
know yourself know your money i was
trying to figure out what that said okay
and uh you'll want to pre-order it
because if you pre-order it before
january the 4th you can get 150
in free gifts so you got about a week
and you need to get this done
uh so also while you're there at
daveramsey.com check out the
90 off a lot of things there
our green monday sale lots of ten dollar
items including rachel's contentment
journal which is now ten dollars
uh her former new york times
best-selling books
our number one best sellers are 10 my
books are 10
so check it out online at daveramsey.com
get the new book and get the uh get the
ones that have been out a while for 10
bucks each
lots of bargains there lots of things
that you can do
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five colorado springs
michelle
is with us hi michelle how are you i'm
doing well thank you for taking my call
sure how can i help so um
my husband and i are in small business
for a few years
and a business mentor has been
mentioning
having key man insurance for our
business
on the case of our death wanted to get
your opinion on that or if there's
anything
else that you would suggest that's in
our will
regarding our business uh are you the
sole owners
yes we own the business okay well
key man insurance is typically used to
buy a partner out
that's the that's the most common use
for it um
the other time you would use it is just
to replace the
the talent that is gone when the person
passes away
the things that they're able to do that
are unique to them
and so it's going to leave a gaping hole
and so
as an example if you are driving the
business and you're making the business
run
and you not being there it's going to
walk with a limp for a while
uh then yeah you might want to put some
key man on you
okay all right i i i but i
i had i've done that a time or two here
where i had some
a particular person that was um
at the stage of business we were in that
if they had passed away during that
you know three year period of time or
something that it would have really left
us
um we would have been in a mess because
we were building the whole thing around
that
and and i have covered them for that um
and i have kept some key man on me
uh just to make sure something happened
to me that it would backfill
some of the uh until the business got to
where it can run
without me which it is now it's easily
running without me these days but um
but back in the day when it was all dave
dependent you know
uh then i carried some key man then you
do not use whole life life insurance for
this you use term life insurance
michelle what kind of business is it
we need to use commercial cleaning so
we're feeling the building's kind of
like girls
okay okay so what would happen to the
business
if your husband passed away oh that
that's the problem
he is the key man yeah okay so what does
he do that makes him so key
um he is basically the operations
manager
i mean he and everything i mean he is a
do everything guy okay and what's your
what's your top line what's your gross
revs in a year
oh my goodness um
probably about 300
okay all right you know i might put 100
on him
or something like that to patch you
through a third of a year maybe 200 even
pass you through a portion half of a
year but you know if he passes away
you're either going to turn around and
sell this thing
or you're going to put an ops manager in
place to replace his day-to-day
activities
right and so you're just you would you
just do you just put you know you just
need to stop gap
because you if you if you replace the
ops manager within 30 days of him
passing and they're competent
you're not going to lose much revenue
but just to make double sure
carry a couple hundred on him with extra
that wouldn't be a bad idea
it wouldn't be in the world and that way
you can cover for some lost revenue
maybe even a signing bonus to get a good
ops manager in there
um and i'll tell you what a lot of
people do in your situation
uh too and if that were to come up um
they put an ops manager in there with
the plan that that person is going to
buy the business from you
because that and that's your exit
strategy then uh so we see that a lot as
well when we're working with entree
leadership clients
good question thank you for joining us
melanie is in portland oregon hi melanie
how are you
hi i'm i'm doing great it's awesome to
be able to talk to you
you too what's up um well um
my husband and i would like to know your
opinion on whether we should pay off our
house
now or put our money into
retirement in the kids college so this
is what we've got he just got a bonus
yesterday
that will allow us could allow us to pay
off the house
and still have like six months of
emergency fund left
the issue being he has not been paying
um
the 50 total 15 percent into retirement
we have no
college funds for our kids who are ages
2 to 12.
what's your household in um he works
about 94 000. and what's the bonus
um it was it's about 17 000
and we've got total with the savings
would be about 119 000
in several different bank accounts that
we have
that we could use in the house we owe
about 64 000
on it
[Music]
we you owe 64 000 and you already have
enough to pay off the house
before we have enough to pay off before
the bonus yes we have
yes so why haven't you definitely
i think because i'm risk adverse and my
husband does have some health problems
that
risk aversion because you can pay off
your house
okay because you don't want a mortgage
yeah well that's that's my thought but
his thought is
he want he doesn't have as much
retirement as he wants we have nothing
for them so instead of sitting in a bank
account
yeah we've kind of dropped the bomb the
last couple years he just got this new
job about a year ago so we've not been
making 94 000
for a long time this this new job just
happened about a year ago so we haven't
quite adjusted to
the additional the extra the extra
income yeah yeah yeah
um yeah okay so yeah if i woke up in
your shoes
i'd pay off the house go and pay it off
okay
that was my that was my opinion okay
yeah i would do it making sure that you
still have and i would have for you
six months worth of expenses in the bank
you guys have that in addition right
yes yep or that that would be out of the
119. so i
so we say three to six months of
expenses i would go to six because of
his health problems all of that and i
just like have an extra money there just
feels good the cash is there
so beyond that you guys do need to do
need to take your 15
of your income of his income if you're
not working into retirement that needs
to be a discipline you need to be doing
that and then anything extra that you
guys have
after you paid off the house after the
six months of expenses is there
throw some of the kids college i'd go
talk to a smart investor pro look at an
esa look at a
529 option and start that as well but
you guys need to be disciplined
and that 94k that you're making a year
that 15
of that goes into retirement okay
melanie great okay
well thank you so much we got an edition
yes you cannot take part of rachel's
advice
it'll be bad advice you have to take the
whole thing
it is time to take this blessing of this
job
and this money and be very
intentional with it it's been lazy it's
been
sitting in a lazy bank account it's time
to put the whip on it and make it work
pay off the house start the 15 with a
smartvestor pro and start the kids
college by the end of january
you have an assignment by the end of
january no excuses
put that money to work it is sitting
over there being
lazy and you allowed it don't allow it
to be lazy
put the whip on it this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how would you like to make your money
finally behave like we were talking
about with
her you know you make it go and do what
it's supposed to do because you have an
exact plan a clear path and you know
exactly what to do when to do it
and then you go do it because you've got
cheerleaders in your corner coaches
cheering you on you got people telling
you do it right don't do
don't go left go right showing you
exactly what to do this is what happens
when you get into ramsay plus it's our
step-by-step
money plan that'll help you pay off your
debt really fast
faster than maybe you ever dreamed and
you can start spending and saving then
how you want to because you don't have
your freaking payments you'll learn
practical ways to pay off more debt and
save for emergencies you'll plan your
spending
in the world's best budgeting app every
dollar
and you'll track your progress you can
get a free trial
to ramsey plus all you got to do to get
2021
rocking and get your reset get things
started i mean after this year you need
to get started right
ramsey plus for the free trial just text
the word
trial two three three seven eight nine
text trial two three three
seven eight nine mike is in rock hill
south carolina hey mike welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i feel like we have hit a sort of a
brick wall
we are trying to build a house
and are having no luck without a credit
score so far
okay i've talked to some folks at
churchill
and according to them they go through
local lenders for a construction loan
yeah and every local lender has requires
a credit score to get started
even though we have at least twenty
percent down it's not way more than that
okay and i just don't know what you try
to have you tried a credit union
i have i've worked with my credit union
i've been with since i was born
and they do manual underwriting but they
tell me they have to have a credit score
to get started
and then they go from there i'm
challenging that they don't have to
because they're portfolioing that loan
they're not selling that loan to anyone
that's just an underling you need to get
to a manager a senior
the president of the credit union
depending on how what size the credit
union is
they do not need a credit score to make
a construction loan that's absolutely
asinine
i don't believe it okay i would bust up
on some people now
you know bank of america is not going to
make you a construction loan without a
credit score i don't have any doubt but
i'm not doing business with those
doofuses anyway
so but your local bank i mean we're
listen here's the thing if you're
dealing with a mortgage like a fannie
mae mortgage
you can get that manually underwritten
but most of the mortgage companies
don't know how to do it because fannie
mae requires a credit score
to package them together or properly
done manual underwriting which not many
people other than church you'll know how
to do
okay so that you will run into problems
there and there's a valid reason for
that because they're packaging those
loans together they don't keep those
loans they sell them
and in order to sell them they've got to
be packaged a certain way does that make
sense
yes and if the opposite of selling them
in this business is called portfolioing
the loan meaning the bank
keeps the loan in house the credit union
is portfolioing this construction loan
or the local bank is either one
and so they can they can make up
whatever rules they want to make up
there is absolutely no pressure on them
from an outside force of any kind
that's requiring a credit score and so
it's just a dumb butt
policy that you got to bust up into
meaning you got to get somebody use a
brain i've been with you my whole
freaking life
since i was born and i got 20
down and i've got the permanent mortgage
set up to take you
take out the construction loan you're
only going to have the loan on the books
while the house is being built when it's
completed the mortgage is sitting over
here already pre-approved
the take-out letter is in my hand to
take out the construction loan
and so this is almost a no risk for you
you know me
you know my income you know my net worth
and my other stuff or i can show it all
to you and so the credit scores are
completely bogus
non-related issue you follow me
yes so that's how i'm talking to the
president of the credit union or the
manager of whatever or i don't know how
big a credit union this is but
a lot of credit unions the small enough
that the president so you're gonna end
up talking to which is fine
and it's you know it's just asinine and
so this is one of those things you just
challenge the policy
and you just say no it's not okay it's
not okay that you're treating me a
customer that way
as if i somehow didn't pay my bills and
and they do not if they're portfolioing
the loan
if a bank is keeping the loan in-house
the bank can completely make up
whatever rules it wants to make up or
waive
any rules it wants to waive because
they're keeping the loan it's just like
if i'm loaning you money
i can make up whatever rules i want to
make up and if i go well you don't have
a credit score but you've got all this
other stuff well i don't need a credit
score it's okay
you know and that's all we're talking
about here so uh but yeah you run into
people who've forgotten how to think
and sometimes we have to remind them
well that's the hard thing it's just
challenging the industry right and so
when you don't
have a credit score because you've
gotten yourself out of debts and
it's been a long enough time that it's
not there there are going to be things
insurance renting an apartment
underwriting a mortgage construction
loan all those things
uh you can run up against things because
the industry has been so set
but there are ways around it all yep i
mean anthony sat the other day he's got
it on youtube
and called 15 apartment complexes and
just asked the question he said i'm
moving from out of town
uh i'm just getting started moving on my
parents house i don't have a credit
score can i will you rent to me
and out of 15 12 said they would yeah
there you go with a deposit
with them you know and he said is it a
couple of them had an extra deposit if
you didn't have a credit score
yeah and a couple of them were just now
it's no problem there's no problem at
all
if you got your deposit and you got you
know they have to have proof of income
you have to have a job
yes yes but uh you know normal stuff
that the apartment's going to look at
but this idea that no apartments were in
two without a credit score he got a 12
out of 15 that would and he didn't say
i'm anthony o'neil he just called and
said
hey i'm just checking i'm coming out i'm
moving from out of town and you just
and he put it all on youtube so you can
pull it up on the ao's channel and see
that somebody says oh you have to have a
credit score for getting a run apartment
no you don't
oh you know 12 out of 15. dentists agree
complexes agree yeah 12 out of 13
apartment complexes agree
all right up next is going to be steve
steve is in phoenix hi steve how are you
hi dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure how can i help
yes um i have a mortgage
with a principal of interest left of 277
000 and i have 1.6 million dollars in my
401k
and i was wondering if i should pull
that money out in one lump sum
or spread it across a couple years for
tax
purposes to pay off my mortgage
how old are you 66.
okay uh you could sit down with your tax
preparer
and decide if you wanted to do it over
two or three years just to not
bump up a tax bracket but i think you're
going to bump up a tax bracket anyway
is my guess um i mean you could look at
tax planning this and make it doing it
the most tax efficient way
i got to tell you you've worked your
whole life and i'm guessing you didn't
it did not inherit this money because
it's in a 401k right
that is correct and you're 66 years old
and you got a million seven
way to go congratulations i
i think you worked your whole life to
have more peace than you've got with a
mortgage so
regardless of the tax situation if i
were in your shoes i'd probably just pay
it off
i want to be out of debt and i'm going
to pay some taxes to do that because
this is a taxable account when you cash
out a 401k traditional
and so to get 277 out you're probably
going to take out 377
something like that and so your net
worth is not going to change one penny
it's going to be exactly the same
the only difference is you'll have more
equity in a house and less equity in
your 401k
still have 1.3 and still have 1.3
in the 401k yeah yeah exactly so you're
still gonna be
a millionaire in 401k alone not to
mention you're paid for house
i want the piece of a paid for house and
i it's just as i
there's few things i've done in my life
that compare with the day i paid off my
mortgage
in the financial parts of my life uh you
take your shoes off walk through the
backyard the grass just feels different
the borrower is slave to the lender
and i know you've got the money i know
you can pay it off anytime you want so
so my answer to that is do it yeah i
would do it
good question sir thank you and
congratulations on being an everyday
millionaire
you're what makes america great you guys
people like that guy right there they're
everywhere
they're all over america and they're
real quiet hardly anybody knows they're
there
there's about 12 million guys just like
him
and her and gals like him and her
they're all over the place
that puts us out of the dave ramsey
showing the books thanks to james childs
our producer kelly daniel our associate
producer and phone screener i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have live from the headquarters
of ramsey solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the dave ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and my daughter
is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five jerry's going to start
us off this hour jerry's in columbus
ohio
hi jerry how are you okay how are you
better than i deserve what's up i was
just calling um
my wife and i are retired teachers in
ohio and the way the
pensions claim is set up when one of us
passes the other one still gets the same
income do we need to have life insurance
sure
okay so the next question is what if one
of us can't get a policy
well then i guess you're not gonna have
life insurance what do you mean why
wouldn't you be able to get a policy
my wife's been diagnosed with
alzheimer's and we went through xander
and they couldn't find a policy for no
you're not gonna make you're not gonna
make a market on that that's right i'm
sorry
okay so uh so she's got early onset then
um yes and the thing is we didn't go
through your book but we are on step
seven we have no debt
we're investing worse and cost giving so
everything's paid off and
um and her income comes to you
as long as you're alive once she passes
through the school system right
or vice versa yeah either way okay
and how old are you guys um
she's i just turned 70. i'm 64.
okay all right um
and what other monies do you have other
than a paid for house and these two
pensions
we each have our own roth iras
i've got a 403 b how much and we've got
um in in those accounts about 350 000
okay i think you're all right to call
yourself self-insured if you want to
here's the rule of thumb okay number
number one
and the income the pension probably does
you're probably right
um but with the other things the paid
for house and the 350 000 it definitely
is there
because you've got some flexibility so
the question we ask ourselves is
at 64 years old she's 70 and got early
onset
alzheimer's or or alzheimer's diagnosis
if something happened to you we've got
to be concerned that she's cared for
right
and we've already made that arrangement
yeah well the the actual tactical care
is one thing but paying for it
with your both of your pensions and the
350
um i think gonna she'd be okay right
yeah so you're probably self-insured you
reverse the question
something happens to her are you okay
well even more so you're okay right
yes right so yeah you're self-insured
i'm good with that okay
the purpose of life insurance is make
sure the one left behind has got food
right yeah yeah well we're both retired
like i said we're actually
still saving yeah and giving yeah
well way to go investing and you did all
this on a teacher's salary
uh yes congratulations your salaries
well done
that was beautiful right it's awesome
love that very cool that's the position
you want to be in
well done amy's in philadelphia hi amy
welcome to the dave ramsey show great
thanks so much for having me it's good
to talk to you guys
you too what's up um so i have a
question for you all um
calling for my mom actually she was my
grandmother's caretaker for years
um she had to quit her job to take care
of her she did a great job
but unfortunately she didn't save
anything and
she now lives on her social security my
grandmother
passed away a few months ago and she did
though just now
inherit eighty thousand dollars so it's
a great blessing
and she asked my husband and i to um
you know to help her with this so i
already had her an everyday budget
she lives in a small apartment and um
you know we're just having her live on
that but we want we told her
you know this is her nest egg and she
really just doesn't want to
mess it up this time she said so she
wants to do it wisely do it god's way
and um we want to help her through that
so basically
where i'm calling you to see what would
be the steps um
you know how do we walk her through this
how do we help her with investing what
would be the right way
just not sure at this point okay yeah i
mean
my my first piece of advice would be to
sit down with one of our smartvestor
pros because they're going to be able
to lay out things like what a mutual
fund is putting it in some kind of
account like that that grows
and that she's able to say okay how much
is my lifestyle how much do i need per
year
how much return do i need they're going
to be able to really sit down and
mathematically
walk you through because that's that's
the answer she's going to need how much
does she
need to live on per year what can this
money do what can it grow to how much
can she live off of
yeah so you've got her set up now living
on her social security right
right right and in our heads we just
thought you don't touch it and you just
just invest interest just let it just
let it grow a little i mean
it'll grow eight to ten thousand dollars
a year okay
something like that if it's invested in
good mutual funds i'm probably not going
to invest the whole 80 i'm probably
going to set maybe 10 aside as her
emergency fund
okay in a separate in a separate bank
account that's not connected to the atm
and it's not connected to a checking
account or a debit card
okay so it requires effort to get to it
okay great and then i'm probably gonna
do it exactly what rachel said and let's
sit down with the smartvestor pro
because you don't want to invest the
money and
she starts watching the news and the
stock market goes down
and she starts calling you in a panic
instead if you know she needs to
understood what she's doing enough she
doesn't have to become a professional
investor
but she needs to understand and what
rachel's explaining is exactly that that
they'll sit down with her and not only
help with the budget and
you know we're not going to touch this
money we're going to leave it alone mom
you're going to leave on
you're going to live on your social
security and okay we're going to let
this money roll in
each month and each year as it grows
and but you don't want to you don't want
her to losing
sleep over this because the market
feeling like feeling like she did
something wrong and the way to solve
that
is to teach her and teach you both of
you and to have a person in your corner
that you trust that has the heart of a
teacher so click smart investor at
daveramsey.com and sit down with them
and they can help you do every
bit of that very good question very good
job
well if you're looking for some great
christmas deals there's still some out
there our team is using
every reason we can to give stuff away
we're now running a sale the green
monday sale all week this week at almost
90 percent off
and for the first time ever we've even
marked rachel's contentment journal down
to just ten dollars
plus the window to pre-order the know
yourself know your money book
the brand new book by rachel cruz is
closing if you do pre-order
you get a hundred and fifty dollars
worth of free add-ons
but you gotta do that before january
four
and believe it or not that's just around
the corner it's here the book ships
january the 5th so no more excuses
this new year is the time to understand
yourself
and learn how to make healthy money
choices
and uh rachel cruz will help you unlock
the psychology the strengths the
challenges that come with each of the
brand new seven
money tendencies found in her book check
it all out online at daveramsey.com
the sale on all this stuff ends this
coming sunday
and you don't want to miss out on this
pretty good stuff it's fun
lots of fun stuff happening yeah closing
out 2020.
a lot of people are going to be helped
with this book that's my prayer for sure
a lot of people and tens of thousands
have already bought it
and it's um when they get it and start
reading it they're going to spread the
word it's it's a
very helpful set of materials this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
ramsey personality rachel cruz is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 jay is in atlanta
hi jay welcome to the show how can we
help
hey dave rachel thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
yes so i'm 24 years old and i got about
18 000
saved up in a raw tsp account um
from when i was on active duty in the
military so my question is
should i roll that over to a roth ira
right now
considering the fact that i'm currently
in school and i'm not working at the
moment
uh you've left the military yes
yes i would it's roth to roth
so there's no taxes involved
and uh you don't you're not going to
activate anything and
you've got 8 000 mutual funds to choose
from where the tsp has about six
options and a c option being the most
valid of all of them
but you can do a lot better than the tsp
options in the open market with mutual
funds to pick
for your new roth and so yeah it's
pretty simple get with the smartvestor
pro at daveramsey.com and roll it
to a roth ira we put it across four
types growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
we always tell you to take your 401k or
your retirement plan whatever it is with
you when you leave
with a direct transfer rollover to an
ira at the other
on your own in because you've got more
selection and more control
it's pretty simple and uh same goes here
thank you for your service by the way
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jessica
is in canada hi jessica how are you
hi dave and rachel thank you for taking
my call
i'm currently on baby step number two
i'm sixty thousand dollars in debt
um i recently started listening to you
so i'm being intentional i'm going at it
because all the times and i've paid off
twelve thousand dollars so far
thanks so i grew up with a very unstable
home when it comes to money
my mother is a very big spender and she
never ever had enough money for the
month
um while i don't blame anyone else but
myself for my bad financial decisions
she's the ones who sort of
pushed me or guided me in the direction
to make poor financial decisions and
all my debt i have is credit cards and
loans so
now that i'm being very frugal she
thinks i'm completely crazy
and she was pushing me to file for
bankruptcy and
every time i see her it's a constant
battle because was
on different pages and i can't seem to
make her understand
that what she's teaching is wrong and
what she's doing is
wrong so i wanted to know your input on
how to approach that situation
how old are you jessica i'm 28 28 okay
well the hard part about the relational
aspect of money
is that some people just don't
understand
and the hard thing is you can't control
them to force them
to see that they are wrong so i would
say on her end
and unless she's asking and
wanting to learn i wouldn't push
you know your your stuff on her because
she's she's not asking
and you talking about it unless it's
celebratory and you're like hey mom i
just paid this off and i'm excited
and you have that kind of conversation
knowing that it's probably not gonna
she's not have the best response i would
probably just
leave finances out of the discussion if
she keeps bringing it up
then there needs to be a boundary put in
place because it's not worth the strain
on your relationship you're doing
something
that is wise with your money and you're
going down this journey
she doesn't agree and so being able to
put up a boundary
and say hey mom since you keep bringing
it up this is what i'm doing i'm 28
years old
this is why i'm doing this because i
want stability i want peace
i want money in the bank and you can
give your reasons why and say
if you don't understand that's okay but
i need your respect enough
for me not to negatively
keep talking to me you don't mean just
having that sometimes you have to just
have a boundary that says we can't talk
about this subject
because if we are going to talk about
this subject we
are not going to do well and i'd rather
have i'd rather do well i'd rather have
the relationship
for instance i have a relative that
votes wrong
they just vote for the wrong people
every time they they have
a knack for it and um and they blindly
vote for one party
regardless and um so
uh which i have no use for voting wrong
or voting for the wrong party regardless
are voting for a party regardless
no matter what i vote for that party no
i that's just ridiculous
and so um but i love them
and what i have figured out is is
they're not going to change
and so just constantly berating them
about it is not going to help
and talking to them about it is not
going to help because it makes me mad
so the best thing to do is just not talk
about
politics with that relative because
they're just wrong
you know and that's kind of what you may
have to do with your mom it's just like
mama i can't talk about money with you
because you and i don't agree on this
and we're just going to find something
else to talk about because we love each
other
and it's just that's you know how's the
weather uh how about them titans
i mean you know i mean it's just you
know it's just
how about the football team you know i
mean you can't find something else and
you
put that boundary in place like rachel's
saying but it's
very difficult to do um and you know
probably the
most difficult boundary is
mother to grown daughter that is one of
the more difficult relationship
boundaries because both are relationship
animals
and they feel entitled they feel like
they have rights
to speak into each other's lives
uh and so they don't you know sometimes
they just don't do well with it and it's
okay to set some boundaries in place
and jessica i would say for you i mean i
heard a little bit of your tone and and
the way you even framed up the question
that there's a little bit of hurt
and resentment towards your mom i mean
you said shh the way i handle money
today is because of what i learned from
her and i'm just
in a terrible spot because of it and so
there is this this interesting dynamic
now that you are a grown adult and
you're working through oh wow
my mom you know did things in my
childhood that i don't agree with
and now because that's how i was raised
i almost just didn't even know to do any
better so that's how you got to this
place
i'm glad you're changing everything
because there's a rule jessica and the
rule is once you're 30 you can't blame
your parents anymore okay you always say
that i don't agree
it's not that i put blame but there is
real hurts and things that go on no i
know i know but you can't blame them
you can you can be hurt yeah you can't
here's my quote i love this quote
when it comes to talking about your
parents you're not here to bash them
and i heard a little bit right like oh
right here to bash them we're not here
to defend them
we're here to tell the truth so you tell
the truth jessica like tell the truth of
of what you experience and then learn
from that and grow
and so i think both of the other ends
extreme are unhealthy because you're not
getting to the root
emotion of your mom so there's a
relational aspect there too jessica i
would really dig into and if there's a
level of hurt and resentment you may
talk to someone about that i mean
there's i think all of that is very
healthy
don't disagree you always say that once
you're 30 you can't blame your parents
well you can't
you can't it's not polite you're
you just don't like the statement but
awareness that once you're past 30
you can still have hurt from your
parents you can say i've heard but you
can't blame him but i'm not speaking out
of experience
he has never ever done anything
yeah oh yeah we should start a new radio
show yeah
we'll just start a new one here
confessions confessions of the rams
the uh uh so there's a difference
there's a difference in hurt and blame
though
all right doctor tell me well you can
still have you can you can be
hurt yes and admit that there's a wound
there
yes and but you can no longer uh let
that be
the reason that you're not winning yes a
hundred percent that's what i mean you
can't blame them
it's not blame is it's someone else's
fault i'm not winning
yes and that is not it is not no it's
not your parents fault you're not
winning once you're 30. it's your fault
i don't know why i keep saying 30.
that's just well i just made it up
it's not it's not a scientific fact it's
just a davis
all right guys she's got 28. she's got
two years to go she's still okay oh good
yeah
you got plenty of time jessica you're
gonna make it oh crud
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life
and your money that's a lot of what i
talk about though in the new book with
the
classrooms so she grew up in an unstable
money classroom
where the emotional the emotional
communication was very stressed
and the verbal communication was
probably very open knowing how her mom
was out so she felt a lot of that
conflict and tension growing up
and so that unstable money classroom if
it does affect you all the classrooms
affect you and that does leave
a hurt it leaves a wound that you
learn to overcome absolutely not
not to blame for your dysfunction and
that's why i know yourself know your
money's gonna be great yeah that's right
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life and money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five zack is in nashville hey zach how
are you
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
ah thank you for taking my call um okay
my question is me and my wife
we are both in our early thirties i'm
currently 34 she's 32.
we're pretty well debt-free i guess my
question is i
owe 80 000 on my house right now i'm in
the position to pay it off
i haven't invested in anything and i'm
still learning that process
but i guess do i pay the house off now
or do i maybe start the roth iras or go
that route
i i don't know what the best answer is
that's the reason for my call you said
zach that you can pay off the house so
does that mean you have i'm guessing a
lot of savings
uh yeah i've got about a hundred
thousand dollars and i
and my wife both and like i said that
leave us about
20. um i just
i've been pretty focused on paying the
house off if i keep track right now i'm
paying extra to the principal it
probably put me at about five years
i guess i'll have it paid off yeah how
much do you make a year
about 62. that's great
well what i would do zack is considering
you have no other consumer debt you have
a good amount of savings
i would work to still fund some money
into retirement i mean the earlier you
can start this
the better off you're going to be even
three to four years the fact that you
guys can start
in your early 30s is going to be huge
and so i would fund about 15
of your income into retirement so
opening up a roth ira
if your work has a 401k do that do you
guys have kids
yes i've got two little girls one's
seven and one's a year and a half
okay do you have any college savings for
them at this point
i do not i'm very new to the baby steps
and
like i said i was trying to figure out
what the best yeah
would be no you're doing great being in
the position yes absolutely well you're
yeah you're in a fantastic position on
paper for sure so yeah i would fund 15
of your income to retirement then i
would go and open up some
college funds for your girls so either
an esa or a 529 plan put some money
there
and then anything extra that you have
that you want to throw at the house i
would do that i would make sure you
still have an emergency fund on the
side of three to six months of expenses
but anything beyond that
i yeah i would look to to be putting the
house down
did i hear you right that you have a
hundred thousand dollars in
savings and eighty thousand pays the
house off
correct yes i know that money's just
sitting there i know i'm just asking if
i
if i understood you right and i wasn't
being sarcastic so if i understood you
right then
rachel's advice is perfect uh but i
would write a check today and pay off
your house
okay and that's kind of been my question
yeah then the other the other 20 000 the
other 20 000 moves over into your
emergency fund
and then out of your income without a
house payment
boom right yes now in your monthly
budget you set up a draw
going into your 401k or your roth iras
like rachel's talking about
or your company's plan or whatever or or
sit down with smartvestor pro and you
may want to sit down with them anyway
and then have
you know if you just start a hundred
bucks a month uh per kid it would go a
long way towards their college as young
as your kids are
and so um yeah i'd sit down and get at
least 100 bucks a month going per kid
and and at least 15 of your income going
towards retirement and without a house
payment or any other payments in the
world you're gonna have plenty of wiggle
room in this budget to do that
yeah and that's that's kind of been my
question it was like because it frees me
up a lot once you pay that once i pay
the house off
i just didn't know if that was the best
move let me just tell you i've been
doing this 30 years and i've been
telling people for 30 years to pay off
their house every chance i got
i've never had anybody call me up and
was pissed because they paid off their
house
exactly like dave that's the worst
advice you ruined my life
dave i've never heard that not one time
people get pissed at me about a lot of
stuff i get a lot of hate
but it's never been about paying off
your house so
i get i do apparently i make most people
mad about a lot of things but that one
not people don't get mad about that one
zach hold on i'm going to give you a
copy of the total money makeover
which has the baby steps outlined in it
on steroids every detail every nuance
every question answered about the baby
steps
shows you exactly what to do when to do
it and how to do it
and it will verify the conversation that
you had with rachel and i
and i put you in a great position here
brother and what an amazing thing 34
yes way go man paid for house tomorrow
if you wanted just like
i mean the number of people do that
almost none
almost none and then to the point though
zach of not having the house payment you
have no other debt
when your income comes in and you're
completely debt free you have no other
payments
that 15 is easily put away and then you
guys because
because i could i i would think living
with this hundred grand of cash over
here feels good
like there's a level of security there
and when that strips down to 20 there's
going to be like oh wow
but building that back up without a
mortgage payment is going to happen
so quickly well 20 000 is plenty of an
emergency fund with 60 000
income no it is but i'm just saying just
the thought of oh yeah we could go buy a
car we could do other things with that
money
yeah that short-term savings is to
happen so
quickly without that mortgage payment so
that feeling of it but listen to this
this is what i think cool
32 to 62 32 to 67
35 years if he just invests if he never
gets a raise
now if you go 40 years at your job and
you never get a raise you're a loser
okay but if he never gets a raise
and he only invests 15 not more
just 15 that's going to in good mutual
funds in a roth iras
he's going to have between five and
seven million dollars
making 60 grand because he did this so
early
that's that kid's on fire man that's
cool
see that's what that's why we tell you
to pay off the house because it makes
you rich that's right yeah
and you be in a position to be
outrageously generous you know what you
can do with five to seven million
dollars
anything you want i mean and what if i'm
half wrong
he's still okay i mean still okay that's
unbelievable
so this is why nobody gets mad at me for
telling you to pay off their house they
get mad about everything else but they
don't get mad about that
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
james is in philadelphia hi james how
are you
hi dave how you doing today good how can
we help
good um i just had a quick question so
um
my wife is in 139 000
of student loan debt we recently just
purchased
a home about two months ago
really the only debt that we have is the
house
and her student loans we have no car
payments um
no credit card debt nothing like that i
just want to know the best way to
tackle her student loan bet should you
know whether
we should just like pay half of it and
then refinance it or just save up for
the whole thing and
just want to know the best way to tackle
it how much do you guys make
james a year um so my
my wife makes about 42 uh
42 000 a year i am a loan officer
i worked be basically commissioned
but my year to date should be about like
260 000
uh this year why did she go 140 000
in debt making 40 000 a year what is she
doing
um so she went to a private institution
um she was originally going for um
like fashion merchandise and marketing
um very niche market
uh to really break into um so it was
pretty hard to find
a job um but yeah
so here's what i would do um if you make
300
000 a year and you have 130 000 in debt
i would pay off your debt in one year
okay 140 140 from 300 leaves you plenty
to live on
okay like we have we have about like
66 000 66 000 in the bank now
good right that's write that check
against it and then you're paid off in
six months
okay you're not going to do any of this
are you
it's no no i am it's just it's it's hard
to let go of the money
like yeah i mean that would that would
be draining the bank account like that
would be complete dude
you have to get rid of this sally mae is
an ugly old woman and she's in your
house and she won't leave until you
throw her out
and the faster you throw her out the
faster you're going to get on with your
life
let me tell you the problem with paying
off your student loan debt you're not
going to do it
that's the problem you're going to have
to get on this
like it matters and if you don't it's
going to hang around for another 10
years and you'll have a bunch of
theories
and still have sallie mae in your
bedroom this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day hebrews 13 16
do not neglect to do good and to share
what you have
for such sacrifices are pleasing to god
ralph waldo emerson said the purpose of
life
is not to be happy it is to be useful
to be honorable to be compassionate
to have it make some difference that you
have lived and lived well
[Music]
and oddly enough by the way i'll add
that that will make you happy
go figure uh michael is with us
michael's in dallas texas
hey michael welcome to the dave ramsey
show how you doing dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up i had a quick question
um i had a two-part question if i'm able
to have enough time
um so my uncle pretty much just
purchased a new vehicle
and i was trying to teach your ways to
him
and you know just trying to find out why
he
didn't just buy out cash when he had the
money available to him
and his response was you always need a
line
you always need something open a line of
credit open
and in my head i didn't want to argue
with them so i'm just thinking in my
head
well why would you want the line of
credit open if you have the cash and you
have no debt
you're right yeah that's just uh
that you know people have these sayings
around debt that because debt is so
normalized
and they don't even think sometimes when
they say stuff about how ridiculous what
they're saying
sounds i mean what he just said is
i always want to be in debt
yeah this company doesn't have a house
or anything like that so that's all it's
just like yeah um but you have a credit
card you know you do fire points and
stuff like that okay i can understand
that but
no i don't even understand that second
my second quick question was i have my
kids
in a gerber uh savings plan
and i was trying to find out because me
myself i have a roth account
and i was trying to see about how do i
go about to see if i'm able to transfer
the funds that are in their gerber
account into
a roth or an ira or what would be good
for them it wouldn't be a roth or an ira
just be opening a 529 and it's not
transferring you just cancel that
garbage
and get a good mutual fund in your kids
name for for a 529 plan
um gerber is baby food company they're
not an investment company
and they sell gimmick life and whole
life life insurance
as a savings plan that's a piece of crap
and it's horrible
it's absolutely horrible so uh if i were
in your shoes i would get with a
smartvestor pro
open a 529 or an esa for your child
and just cash this stuff in and use that
money to fund it
yeah okay go a step further because you
said it's horrible because i get
as a mom when i had babies all the baby
stores know you're pregnant so you get
all these brochures so you get gir i
mean i got so many of those flyers
and it's horrible because the rate of
return of what they're taking
is so small explain when you say it's
horrible to a new listener what does
that mean
well it's a whole life life insurance
policy yeah for children
and so which they don't need life
insurance it's a savings vehicle
yeah uh that pays almost nothing
and it's housed in the life insurance
world and
you know anytime you get around
insurance of any kind
that is a gimmick meaning it's it's
aimed at
some kind of little weird corner of the
world like this is
life insurance for children for babies
for god's sakes
uh or it's a savings program for babies
brought to you by the same people you
buy your baby food from you should that
right there is your clue you know
so you know gimmicky insurance is like
cancer insurance okay you have health
insurance that covers you if you have
cancer
you don't have heart attack insurance
why are you buying cancer insurance
because you already have health
insurance that's why you're not and
these are gimmicky things
another gimmicky one is um accidental
death
like you're more dead if you die by
accident
you're still just dead it doesn't matter
you're not double dead
you know and so your family needs money
regardless of how
you die well i'm likely to die by
accident
no you're not that's why it's so cheap
that it's a it's a gimmick it's why it's
you know it's it's like a
a war an extended warranty that only
covers one side of the television the
other side it doesn't cover
you know it's like right you know it's
that kind of thing so you just don't get
into that
and then you have um
you know other other issues so yeah it's
just a
bad gimmicky ineffective low return
life insurance product for children
and um yeah and it's it's uh
yeah it's one of those things where the
parents the the company knows you have
this emotional need to
when you have a baby to do something
good for them and think about their
future and your noble calling is
apparent
and they tap into all that and sell you
crap
all right seth is with us in dallas
texas hey seth how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
so i have a uh well i've made a genius
decision
and bought a car i uh got it on a zero
percent car loan
and could potentially pay it off it's a
five-year
loan but i could pay it off in about a
year's time
does it make sense for me to put that
money
in some sort of investment vehicle or
should i hang on to the
loan at zero percent
i've met with thousands of millionaires
i've never met one that said dave you
know i made all my money borrowing zero
percent of my car and investing it
sure so the answer is get out of
consumer debt because that's what all
millionaires do
they stay away from payments of any kind
all the studies all the data points we
have from 30 years of doing this
all say that the people who build wealth
are the ones that stay
out of debt of any kind or if they find
themselves in debt like you have sir
they work their way out as fast as they
can and so i would either sell this car
or i would get it paid off in about nine
or ten months
i could do that that's pretty much what
i was looking for yeah and then you take
those payments you never do this again
you pay cash for your cars from now on
and that's the shortest distance between
where you are in millionaire
that's the point because the payment
your most powerful wealth building tool
is not the manipulation of interest
rates
it is your income not given to some
stinking bank
in the form of payments and so stay out
of the payment business
and use the power of your income to
build wealth with
and that's that's what the borrower is
slave to the lender means
it changes everything okay i mean when
your income is completely freed up
and you invest it and you just watch it
grow while you're sleeping i mean it's
just
it just goes it work it literally is
working for you money works harder than
any employee you'll ever have
it works all the time it works 24 7. it
never gets sick
it doesn't whine it just works it's
amazing
i mean it works hard brian is in
owensboro kentucky hey brian welcome to
the dave ramsey show
how's it going um so
my question is uh i have a hard time
saving money my wife gets on my butt
about not
not uh saving but my problem is as i
grew up
not having a whole lot so when i get
paid i'm like i want it i'm buying it
i'm getting it now
uh instead of thinking about anything
else
okay uh so i need to know how can i
break myself for that habit and save for
my family you know i'm how old are you
i'm 43 but let can i give you one
example sure i'm getting ready to
do a job in spring hill tennessee
next week at the gm plant i will be
there for about three weeks
and in that three weeks i will make
about 11 500. good for you
um and now you're growing up and you
decided that you probably shouldn't
spend it all on friday and then say
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
right so but my big thing is like
i'm short on time rachel i'm gonna make
rachel jump in here what do you think
well brian i mean i would i'm glad
you're recognizing it so i would sit
down with your wife you guys need to do
a budget together
and you need to start saving you need to
save a thousand dollars you guys need to
be working to get out of debt and then
save three to six three to six months of
expenses
and it's literally the habit the habit
of changing and you're always going to
be a natural spender
it's okay i'm a natural spender actually
you're a natural spender but you have if
i'm not
why do you safe i yeah for me my
motivation to save is so that i can do
stuff
yep so for some people about something
better later and i bet your wife would
say
she saves for security she wants the
level of security no we're gonna be okay
i save so that i can do things so it's
not like you can never do anything again
brian you're just gonna save for it
and make sure you have that cushion
though of of an emergency fund
i figured out i can spend more if i save
and i can give more
if i save and so i i don't save for
savings sake i save for those other
things
and that's that's the way you can do it
there's a purpose to it yeah
that puts this hour the dave ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
so
[Music]
you